the psychology of the criminal mind has
fascinated people forever
books about true crime shows about fake
crimes all the crimes we love it we love
watching it all
unfold right but at a time when i
thought i'd seen it all
one case drew me back in and reminded me
why these investigations
are so addictive it's a case with a
twist where the scammers actually turn
on one another
and the psychology of why they did it
just hugged me
it was so ridiculous when i first heard
it that i decided to dig deeper and
just break it down for your viewing
pleasure our story starts a few days ago
not just minding my own business
watching the clinton news network
when suddenly i heard an update on
instagram star
hush poppy an instagram influencer who
posted pictures
of his lavish lifestyle could spend the
next 20 years
in a prison cell ramon abbas aka
hush puppy has pleaded guilty to money
laundering
in a u.s federal court now okay if
you're a long time
zilla holder pump to stock uh you know
that we've covered hush puppy before
when he went to jail but the details on
this case
we haven't covered let me set the stage
for you
hush puppy real name raymond abbas was
able to flex on instagram and gain
millions of followers based on the
appearance of being a successful real
estate mogul
in reality it was because he ran
something called a bec
scheme it's a type of confidence scam
where you convince someone to send you
money because
you impersonate some kind of business
email in this case hush puppy was
pretending to be a wells fargo
banker and hush puppy convinced his
victim that he could get him
a 15 million dollar loan to build a
school
in qatar this is the case he was charged
on
now maybe this victim wanted to save the
kids i don't know but how this thing
worked
is they tricked the victim into sending
money first
because they said there were taxes on
this multi-million dollar loan
and you might be asking yourself how in
the world did they get
anyone to fall for this well complex
scams like this
aren't easy to pull off you need tons of
fake proof of your identity and hush
puppy had a few people he recruited to
his team
to help pull off this deception the
first
was a guy named juma who pretended to be
from kenya
and provided the loan he was the source
hush puppy
was malik a banker at wells fargo and
they also
had a third guy vincent the tech guy he
set up
phony wells fargo websites and even a
fake wells fargo
automated phone number all to convince
the victim that he really did receive a
loan and on the surface
this fateful job was going off like any
other they'd already convinced the
victim to send
hundreds of thousands of dollars to them
but behind the scenes
things were getting a little rocky with
the team vincent
the third man he was upset he wasn't
happy with how much he was being paid
or how fast he was getting paid and he
decides you know what
this scheme isn't that hard for those
other guys you know he was the one doing
all the work setting up the tech
why not cut hush puppy and juma out of
the deal
so he contacts their victim and tells
them hey
you're being scammed that's right he
basically says
i'm here to help you if you just start
redirecting those scam payments to me
i'll save you from the scammers now at
the time
juma and hush puppy didn't know this but
they were also
planning to cut vinson out so imagine
their surprise when the word got out to
them that they had been beaten to the
punch
now they were the ones being cut out and
guess what they're outraged
on january 16th 2020 hush puppy
then decides it's time to take things to
the next level and he threatens vincent
i swear with my life you will regret
messing with me
you will even wish you died before my
hands will touch you and that same day
hush puppy also contacts a fixer this is
someone who
solves inconvenient problems in this
case it's nigeria's deputy commissioner
abba kyari and if you're in disbelief
right now
yes a scammer just called the police on
another scammer
but this isn't just any cop kyary was
known as a super cop
and this guy was bad news he used to be
part of
sars the special anti-robbery squad
which got disbanded after its
many many abuses of power in nigeria and
so
this is the guy hush puppy calls and he
simply
tells him the truth haj's puppy said
vincent contacted
the job to divert the job for himself
and he didn't pretend it wasn't a scam
they both knew they're talking about a
scam job
but according to the court record hush
puppy asked kyari
to have the police pick this guy up and
give him the serious beating of his
life that's a quote he also told the
corrupt cop
i will take care of the team also after
they pick him up
meaning pay off the whole team of cops
kyary confirmed
yes four days later hush puppy gets sent
a picture
of this guy vincent he's been arrested
the cop
had done his job hush puppy tells kyari
let me know
how i can send money to the team sir let
them deal with him like an armed robber
kyary responded okay
i will send their account details to you
hush puppy also wrote and this is the
part that i just
cannot wrap my mind around he betray me
and try to take
food out of my mouth this is great
punishable sin
i want him to suffer for many years
kyary responded
now okay this is the part my brain can't
understand
a scammer just told a cop to throw
the book at someone who stole money from
him
while also himself stealing money
from people overseas and we know that he
planned to steal money
even from vincent his partner so he's
mad and thinks it's evil to steal from
your partner
while also stealing from his partner it
doesn't make any sense
and this is the thing like when he
eventually got caught i wonder
i'd love to know what he had told the
judge like did he beg for mercy
after wanting to let his partner rot in
a jail cell on trumped-up charges like
i don't know this is just such a dark
story of really ugly people who
ultimately got caught
but the reason they were eventually
captured is likely
in part due to this falling out they had
i can't say i feel bad for them
i just wish i knew why they couldn't see
themselves for how they truly
are bad people i don't know
i think i need to talk this out with
somebody
hey welcome back can i interest you in a
limited special
barbs do it's aged like fine wine
no nothing today i actually just need to
ask you a question okay yes
i'd leak those texts but i was doing
society a service
that's illegal in the state of virginia
you know what are you talking about
i was just gonna ask you why no one sees
themselves as evil oh
i thought you were gonna ask me about my
threat on kiwi farms
no i i don't even know what that is i'm
asking because i'm stumped in this case
with hush puppy
i mean look he blatantly stole money
from people but then when he gets money
stolen from him
he gets angry about it like can't he see
he's the bad guy
well speaking strictly psychologically
this phenomena has been around for a
while
ever hear the story of two gun crowley
no but it sounds like a badass bad guy
name
yeah but that's just it this guy didn't
see himself as a bad guy
even though he killed people he later
wrote a letter that said
under my coat is a weary heart but a
kind one
one that would do nobody any harm do you
think he actually believed that i have
no idea
but the way i see it this hush puppy
probably thinks the same way
they see all their own faults as
forgivable and
other people's actions as unforgivable
that's just the way it is
colloquially i believe you humans refer
to them as
giant [ __ ] huh that's actually
pretty insightful
thanks but with that out of the way can
we finally talk about chris shan
i've been dying to talk about christian
i have no idea what you're talking about
[Music]
apologize but really somehow you ain't
saying much but
a waster someone with their fame up you
took from
everyone including all your day ones i
can't believe it
still the truth you need a spill you
prove the greed is
real you can't delete it chill from the
start it was doomed to fail
i heard you can't go to the moon from
jail